uh press
media briefing
perfect on rn dr tan
um
um
let's see the surface pro logic
the uh 222 virtual background hold on
here
when you turn on your camera doctor
we'll do some tests uh
my hair is a little uh
once again please continue to stand by
we thank you for your patience
i'll be your moderator so uh joining us
today dr teresa tam chief public health
officer and dr howard new deputy chief
public health officer so we will start
with the remarks and then go to
questions we have until noon
uh dr tam
go ahead merci thank you bonjour to
tattoos following several weeks of
declining activity nationally the
average daily case counts are now
leveling off with continued regional
variability across the country
as public health measures ease
increased levels of transmission are not
unexpected since the sarsko v2 virus is
still circulating widely
severe illness trends are still
declining nationally and in most
jurisdictions with the average daily
numbers of people with covert 19 in
hospitals and in intensive care units in
the past week having declined by 11
percent and 14
respectively compared to the week prior
as we expect the sasko v2 virus to
continuously evolve we are closely
monitoring the domestic and
international situation and preparing
for new variants
the ba 0.2 sublineage of the omicron
variant is increasing in canada but at a
slow rate
while other sub lineages are declining
or stable
the growth rate of ba 0.2
internationally appears to be highest
where there is a combination of low
booster coverage and where ba 0.1 has
not already driven high infection rates
while evidence suggests b 8.2 is more
transmissible than b 8.1
b 8.2 does not appear to be associated
with more severe illness in vaccinated
populations
however it is still capable of causing
severe disease among people without
prior immunity which underscores the
importance of getting up to date with
covert 19 vaccines including a booster
if you're eligible
over the past two years canadians have
shown tremendous capacity to adapt to
change and uncertainty as the pandemic
has evolved
while covert 19 is here to stay we are
now entering a period with more
opportunities for in-person activities
gatherings or trout travel some of us
may be feeling a greater sense of
comfort while others may feel less at
ease
many people in canada may be asking may
be taking into consideration
factors such as covert 19 vaccination
status the level of covet 19 activity
locally underlying medical conditions
and risk to personal contacts to make
informed decisions
this includes choosing activities that
are best for their individual and family
situation and using personal protections
for example to continue wearing a
well-constructed well-fitting mask as an
important added layer of protection even
if not required by local authorities
we know that these proven practices
along with strong protection afforded by
being up to date with your covet 19
vaccines have reduced impact and
severity of the pandemic
i encourage canadians to show each other
compassion and respect as we make
decisions to protect ourselves our
families and our communities especially
those at highest risk
these times of transition can be
challenging and stressful to navigate
if you are having a difficult time know
that you are not alone and help is
available
resources such as wellness together
canada provide people in canada of all
ages 24 hours a day seven days a week
with immediate free and confidential
mental health and substance use supports
including information and practical
tools and confidential sessions with
social workers
psychologists and other professionals
pocket world a free companion app to the
wellness together canada online portal
provides another way to access online
resources and to measure and monitor
aspects of your well-being
indigenous peoples can also contact the
toll-free hopeful wellness helpline
cover 19 continues to challenge us and
impacts us differently depending on our
circumstances so let's continue to do
what we can to support one another as we
navigate the roads ahead
thank you merci meiguich
15 account a different factor calmly
statute of vaccination
the problem
is
professional
population
who
uh next up david thornton uh cbc
hi
um what advice doctors are you giving to
the federal government about vaccine
mandates when it comes to air
and rail travel
and when it comes to federal workplaces
i think our role is simply to provide
the scientific information about
the effectiveness of vaccines for
example
and
so it is up to
the employer and treasury board
to make those decisions
so i think that's
the advice for from our perspective is
is a technical one
um so i know that those policies are
under evaluation or review
um including um for example the the
federal mandates for the federal workers
and so i think um
you know you should certainly follow up
um with
with treasury board
and so what is the science telling you
because i think most canadians can
relate to
knowing someone who's been triple boxed
and they've gotten covered um that's
anecdotal of course that's not a
scientific analysis but
tell us maybe if you can't tell us what
your recommendation is what does the
science tell you about vaccine mandates
at this point and how useful they are
yes i think um
as
everyone appreciates the knowledge about
vaccinations evolve over time and i
think
with what's been the game changer i
think is the omicron variant
which is a vaccine escape variant to a
certain extent the good news of course
is everybody appreciate is that for the
vaccine after two doses is really pretty
good at protecting against severe
outcomes and after a
third dose or an additional dose
that protection against severe outcome
is augmented
what is uh really being looked at is the
impact of the vaccination against
transmission and infection and and that
and also transmission
what we know is that
with the omicron virus
having two doses particularly after a
short period of time the protection
against infection
and potentially further transmission is
is goes really low and you would then
need a third dose to provide some
augmentation of the protection against
transmission
and
infection
and that also diminishes over time
so all of that should be taken into
account
as
the
employer or the federal government
looks at the policies going forwards
at the same time you know i think on
things like transportation etc any
layers of protection to provide
to protect
the traveling public
and to protect each other i think is
always a good idea whether they are
mandated or not and so i think that's
from a public health perspective we're
recommending what i would call vaccine
plus
other layers for now because we're in a
period of uncertainty
where um
you know the the virus is still
undergoing evolution
so getting up to date with vaccines plus
wearing a mask is still a really good
idea just just do that for now
especially if you're at high risk and so
i think within the
con construct of say a transport
corridor or
a workplace um those are the sort of
things that people need to bear in mind
as they make those policies
did you ask your photo up there david
i'm sorry i'm i think i lost track
no yes thank you so much
uh
[Music]
foreign
program
considered as a protection result
dylan robertson winning peg free press
uh hi there uh dr tam i'd like to ask
you a little bit about surveillance
going forward
dr knew kindly spoke to this yesterday
but i wanted to get your
anything new from you as well about what
sorts of talks you're having with the
medical officers of health from the
provinces in terms of what type of
reporting you're expecting going forward
how much of this might resemble flu
watch and if you have any sort of
timeline on shifting from you know this
mode to something permanent that's a
little bit perhaps more scaled back
yeah thank you for that question and it
is a topic of um very life discussion at
this point
partly um
you know all the provinces trying to
adjust to look at what um
you know frequency of reporting for
example that they're doing
but
for sure this virus
is undergoing evolution it's here to say
so there should be an ongoing sustained
surveillance program
and
as you said some of it will be built
upon
existing
programming and infrastructure like flu
watch
so one might expect that
on top of any resurgence is a new
variance
we are going to be building upon a
system of regular reporting
over the year maybe escalating in the
respiratory virus season
and
in conjunction with all the other
respiratory viruses because really you
can't tell in terms of the symptoms
sometimes what you have is that they
must be
more integrated
from lab testing to reporting and
transmitting the information to
the general public
so i think you know building off that
towards the full winter season is very
important but we have to have the
flexibility to escalate testing
to escalate sequencing to escalate
the actual reporting as needed
if
a variant of concern emerges as well so
prepare us to how do how we do that is
really important
and even rapid tests you know rapid
tests if you were to use them more
strategically you wouldn't use it at a
time period perhaps when the virus
circulation is low but you would then
escalate that
should we experience a heightened level
of activity
we are as dr knew probably
indicated yesterday we have built
some really great infrastructure over
the last two years
and
so that's that's actually an enhancement
on anything that we've ever had for
influenza which is great news so the
genomics platforms have been greatly
enhanced and we will continue to do
genomic analysis and make sure as much
as possible our sampling frame of which
viruses get sequenced
is robust going forwards including from
travelers for example and
immunocompromised individuals where
these viruses could mutate so these
sampling elements
are being put in place
wastewater surveillance i think um
has been mentioned as well
right now we have about 60 percent
coverage of the population from some
type of wastewater
testing program
we need to not let that slip we need to
actually enhance that
and i i believe dr new also mentioned
that we wanted to increase that to 80
coverage which in a country as vast as
canada with remote communities um it's
not actually that simple compared to
other countries and looking at
watersheds and and and how we best
capture data from wastewater is been a
tremendous lift by many people so we
will continue to strengthen that as well
and we think that will hold great
promise as an ability
the device going forward is to inform
canadians about the activity within
their within their communities
and
so we'll continue right now we are
certainly continuing the um
mandatory random testing
for arrival travelers again as a
surveillance program to detect variants
of concern
so i hope that answers your question and
of course
on top of regular case reporting from
provinces we have sentinel hospital
networks that can give us a really good
sense of trends in terms of the severity
indicators
and we're working with provinces um on
the issue i would say this is a
long-standing issue of
uh reporting mortality as well in more
real time we've had some gains during
this pandemic but we need to be able to
solidify those gains
yeah the other point i would make it's
interesting uh
that maybe it's kind of overlooked is
also is i think we have a very strong i
think uh surveillance overall with many
components for vaccines and vaccination
and that's going to be very important
moving forward as well right obviously
the data we have in terms of vaccine
coverage even for certain you know
age groups and so on uh certainly helps
us and helps nasty in terms of
developing their recommendations
obviously it's very important as we
continue to roll out vaccines to monitor
for you know adverse events and that
that helps us in terms of uh what we
need to do in terms of uh moving forward
with our vaccine rollout and of course
you know uh you know the fact is that
you know
with with the vaccination as well we can
look at effectiveness so if you do get
cases you know in terms of breakthrough
infections you know transmissibility and
so on that's all part of it so it's not
just about the reporting on the cases
but you know where those cases vaccinate
or not i think it's going to be very
important especially in the covenanting
context as we move forward
thank you uh and as a follow-up i just
wanted to ask about facts role when it
comes to the federal jurisdiction and
some of the restrictions around masking
around vaccine passports i know it's a
very broad question it gets into
workplace policies
but right now we do have a patchwork in
canada where people go into a service
canada office there's a mask requirement
they go to a federal museum it's a
little bit different from what their
province is saying
i'm just wondering what sack's role is
in informing those discussions where
those discussions stand right now if
it's being actively looked at lifting
some of those uh you know masking and
vaccination requirements for
public-facing federal institutions
yes i think um i did just answer that
question and maybe it wasn't
it didn't quite hit the spot for you but
yeah i think the employer the treasury
board um actively examine all these
policies
and our job is really to provide them
with the data that we have in terms of
vaccines vaccine effectiveness
both against transmission infection and
again severe outcomes
and
um you know together with other
considerations but i think the federal
government has taken a very
precautionary approach very thoughtful
approach and it's looking at the phase
approach of removing some of these
uh policies
um and there will be
i think uh individuals who will
such as people who have
immunocompromised conditions and and
other
underlying factors that make them more
concerned about a workplace if there
wasn't some of these
measures in place so i think there'll be
a lot of discussions
between the employer and the unions and
others as well on this matter but i know
that these policies are being
re-viewed and re-examined
as we speak
in
um
canadian press
uh good morning doctors it's laura
osmond from the canadian press
um i wanted to ask you about these cases
that we're seeing going up abroad that
the who is warning about you also of
course mentioned um
the potential for an increase in cases
here in canada as public health measures
are lifted there seems to be less
concern about this potential bump in
cases this time around i'm wondering if
you can sort of
put it into context
given that we are expecting to see
potentially another increase
yes so um
globally
i think all we can say is this virus is
in y circulation and continues to be so
globally most of the
what circulating are omicron
and their sub lineages and we're seeing
ba2 increasing globally
and in particular some of the asian
countries
and
there is also a smaller uptick in some
european countries at the moment
so i think in some of the
global
epidemiology what you're seeing in
particular um
very important lessons one is that
vaccines are very important so
particularly for the high risk
for an area like hong kong where they've
tried to
minimize the the cases
all the way through the last couple of
years
but during that period having vaccinated
the high risk or the uptake hasn't been
optimal
you have a very high mortality
someone like new zealand which also
tries to keep out cases as low as
possible
has had a great vaccination campaign and
we're not seeing that kind of
severe
outcome which comes back down to canada
we have had a very successful vaccine
campaign
there could still be improvements
i think everyone who hasn't been
vaccinated with the primary series
hasn't been boosted when uh their wreck
the boosters are recommended for you
especially the 50 plus go get it now
i think it's still very relevant
messaging for canadians
because all that was going to do is try
and prevent
the escalation and hospitalizations and
keep that under manageable
levels
and we can still do that
even if there's a spring
blip
um we're seeing some of that going on in
the united kingdom and european
countries
it may well happen to us um
but to keep it manageable
get vaccinated back to that question
about mask i think a more common message
not to confuse a general public is that
keep the layer of masking as much as
possible
yes it is a personal decision at this
point when mandates have been removed
which is a difficult period of
adjustment but i would say given the
possibility of the uptick in cases
it's prudent to just wear a mask for
them
so vaccine
plus mask and that will stand us in good
stead as we're moving ahead in the next
weeks
um while we're monitoring of course
europe which is a little bit ahead of us
very carefully and then when you're
traveling of course layer on the
protection especially in a country
where um the virus might be extremely
active but i think the vaccines clearly
are protecting people against severe
outcomes and so
that's i think what collectively in the
canadian health system uh we are resting
on
um and but we must still sort of manage
it quite carefully
um i don't know if that answers your
question but ba2 is definitely
proportionately rising it is more
transmissible what it will do is seek
out pockets
of the population
where the immunization rates are lower
where people haven't been boosted
and where there hasn't been a lot of ba
1
or 1.1 that's that that's those are the
at-risk populations
thanks dr tim um and it sounds like
through this transition phase we're
moving away from
being terribly concerned about the
number of cases and rather focusing on
the outcome so to dylan's point about
surveillance is is that what we're going
to be focusing on is the number of cases
becoming less relevant now that
we're moving into this transition phase
and more people are vaccinated
i think um that that in many senses is
correct but you still need to have good
surveillance that is geographically
representational
and still allows us to monitor trends
and signals so it is still important to
carry on with testing and
looking at those trends at the same time
as of course
monitoring hospitalizations and severe
outcomes that is a must that we must
continue
but things like wastewater signals but
also through
well
covered
well
thought about sampling frames for
surveillance purposes
is still important and
that needs to be worked out and
strengthened with the province and
territories as we're going along
um and then there's the sequencing of
course but you're right in that you know
we we're not counting every case and has
we have never really ever done that
because there's always the tip of the
iceberg
and right now that is definitely not
happening there's a lot more cases out
there than it's been counted we know
that
but right now is is more about
surveillance as a signal detection and
trend uh analysis
and we will be keeping a much closer eye
on the actual rates of hospitalizations
and more severe outcomes
so i don't see any any uh more uh any
hand hands up um but we still have time
for for questions uh anyone wants to
have uh have another question
just let me know
okay laura go ahead
hi doctors just to sneak up one more
question and dr tam you were talking
about what you're expecting
given this rise internationally i just
want to be clear are we expecting our
hospitalizations to remain low given the
situation that canada is in this spring
i think
based on modeling and based on what the
provinces are reporting
um hospitalizations
could certainly come up when cases go up
however um it is expected that that
increase in hospitalization
would be less than what we just saw
and
um we were at
some limit of the abilities of the
healthcare system to cope with the
omicron wave just because of sheer
volumes of cases but going forwards
based on what i have seen from
provincial analysis that they're
expecting their hospitalizations to be
manageable
but i think we do have to watch that
really carefully
and that's why we ask people to get
vaccinated so that the serious outcomes
can be prevented
thank you
thank you uh kevin gallagher ctv news
there we go i'm unmuted sorry about that
thanks this question is for dr tam
you've talked a lot about the importance
of getting a third shot or a booster
shot
um but at the same time we just had you
know the testing of the border limited
for people other than those who are
fully vaccinated however that definition
of fully vaccinated still is just two
shots
um is it time that this the federal
government is that going to be advice
that you give to the federal government
to
change the definition of a full series
or fully vaccinated to those with
booster shots and would that affect
people who are currently you know need
to be fully vaccinated to get on a plane
or a train in canada and also if they're
going to get past testing requirements
at the border thank you
yes so the definition fully vaccinated
for the purposes of border measures is
still staying at
the primary series the two dose at the
moment
um it's actually a very difficult
question because the recommendations for
the booster shot and we we do
think that three doses are important and
i think that that should be
uh clearly stated um but the timing of
the boosted dose
is
um such that
uh it might be quite different for
different groups of people
um so i think
the recommendations for different age
groups could be
slightly different
then
and then you you have to think about
people who've also had an infection and
they then need to
ideally wait um a number of weeks and
maybe you know three months be before
they get
the booster shot so it becomes a very
complicated
um algorithm if you like to work out
um
and the rest of the world
um not only have they not had access to
boosters they haven't
many countries haven't in fact had even
two doses
so
all of this has to be born in mind uh
when
the government makes their policy
decisions so it's not easy and you have
to make it relatively simple
um for travelers
so
um all of that has to be taken away so
at this moment in time um is staying at
the uh primary series of two doses
if there comes a time where a
very severe variant is coming up
and we know it's spreading
then
border
measures can
can always be re-examined
from that perspective as well so having
the infrastructure having the arrive can
having the ability to upload
uh vaccine information continues to be
important in in the event
that
we may recommend
a booster being added but for now i
think that's where we're staying where
we are
um as dr new and others have mentioned
uh
public health is a very
important juncture where
we're shifting the emphasis from
requirements to recommendations
and so even this policy has to be
examined in that light
but because
one of our key objectives is to reduce
the impact on the canadian health system
to those as a vaccine
better if you get three will reduce the
severe outcomes so all these things are
taking into account as we currently hold
our ground right now
but be ready to shift as needed
so um i take it then that under the
current circumstances uh even given the
new
omicron sub-variant that you
where's your evaluation domestically
then in terms of
uh
using vaccine mandates for a booster
shot to encourage more canadians to get
that third shot and i'm wondering too i
hate to double barrel questions but i'm
going to break my own um you know policy
here um adding on to that is there an
idea that you have right now where i
think less than uh around 50 of
canadians have gotten that that shot if
it's under 18 like all canadians it's
below half i've gotten that booster shot
is there a goal in mind that p hack has
for how many canadians need to get that
third shot in terms of having the
optimal outcomes to keep hospitalization
levels and severe outcomes at a low
level or is it like you mentioned an age
thing i'm interested to see if you have
a
sort of a benchmark that you're looking
at when it comes to a third shot in
terms of managing the pandemic going
forward
well i think you know obviously as many
people as possible for those who are
eligible to get the booster should get
it but some of the complexity with that
comes with as you've just mentioned the
differential risk of severe outcomes
through different age groups
the differential risk if you had two of
those as a vaccine
and then you
have omicron and then you get another
dose and the timing of those
but i would say that what is important
so amongst all adults so over 18 years
of age 56
have had the additional dose
and among those you know fully
vaccinated at the moment 62
of them have had that booster so it is
still going up and we would like it to
go higher
but what is
actually important is the
uh the seniors the 80 plus the 70 plus
for example have actually had very high
boosted dose coverage
which is
the most important thing i would say
that there's a gap for the 50 plus
if you haven't got your boosters go get
it for personal protection
um and that would um
you know i think still be very relevant
given the potential for
uh an uptick as the public health
measures are eased
um so
you know there's i i don't think we can
just set a benchmark uh target
except to you know get the rates up as
high as possible
how you get those rates up
i think is what you're asking about
in the role of mandates
and as you've seen across the country
right now
the public health strategy
is moving away from mandates to
recommendations and to use all manner of
other means to increase coverage for the
boosters
in terms of
many different strategies to reach the
under immunized
engaging local and community leaders
using very different differential
access
measures
to get that boost of those up
and so i think that's just a general
trend moving away from and mandating
to recommendations
and making more and more effort to to to
have that recommendation
as we move away from the spring and the
potential um you know monitoring that
upsurge carefully
in the next weeks
then we're looking towards preparedness
for
a varying concern that pops up
but also for the full
so if
boosters rates are not
high enough
leading up to the four one of the first
things
we would look at in our options for the
strategy moving into the four
is to make sure people do get the
boosters on top of that there's also the
questions of the fourth dose etc that
will be uh examined as well but
i think um that's where where the
policies are uh across the country and
the the federal government will sort of
examine the the policies related to the
federal mandate um which i've just
mentioned
but i i don't think that
uh the general trend is to use
vaccine mandates
to incentivize that third dose we we
want canadians to want to get it because
um it makes um
sense from a
protection from serious outcome
perspective there are high risk places
though
where some of these requirements might
be maintained
like long-term care homes and and other
high-risk
settings
thank you doctors thanks everyone have a
good weekend
you